i've been a fan of yours for many many
years i think you're one of the funniest
people in the world
i've been a fan since matt tv days 20
years ago
to today with uh with tiger belly so
given that given your status as a
world-class comedian
how did it feel that you were not
invited to andrew schultz's wedding and
i was
well you were there yeah i was there
i was the least funny person there
and the whole time i was thinking
it's not funny that bobby lee's not here
yeah um
all my life i always felt like people
didn't like me and they didn't want to
invite me to things you know i mean i
think that's fundamentally
the reason why i do what i do
so it really did hurt a lot
and um i had resentments i did some
revenge fantasies
about how i'm going to get revenge on
him and stuff yeah and him specifically
him specifically okay like have a big
wedding invite everyone
you know i mean accept him stuff like
that yeah and then just write him a
letter like see that's how it feels or
whatever
but instead of that i'm because i'm in
therapy and stuff i'm just kind of like
trying to let it go what did you do
there this right here why'd you do that
i forgot to start the timer and now it's
going to start over yeah let's do this
let's do it again
take two no uh you still feel like an
outsider you're exceptionally successful
maybe domain you still feel yeah you
know i'm doing a netflix show tonight
with andre santino at the comedy store
and this nap but like last night you
know i just felt like i wasn't a part of
in fact on stage i go i even mentioned
that i go netflix they don't like me you
know i mean and i just say things like
that um they're not true
and this is something that i want to
correct with myself because i have this
internal dialogue that's based
on just the past and 99 of the things
that go on in my mind aren't true and
i'm just at a point in my life where i'm
just don't want to start i want to start
i don't want to live like that anymore
really because i'm the same way i'm
deeply self-critical all the time yeah
and um that's kind of an engine that
drives you to to do stuff
yeah but it doesn't give you the kind of
freedom
that i would like don't you want to be
truly free free from your mind
free from negative thoughts
no i i'm free part of the day
some of the day i spend being extremely
self-critical and that drives you
because i'm afraid i'll become ultra
lazy otherwise
because i love life i love being
comfortable i love just relaxing i need
very few things in life and so i'm
afraid i'll just get like super lazy oh
are you a minimalist yeah so if i went
to your house in austin do you have a
couch
i recently got this is the first college
i've gotten
ever because the guests were complaining
because i also record uh the podcast
there the guests are complaining there's
nowhere to sit i have no chairs no couch
i sleep on the floor like a mattress is
on the floor
um
not out of principle i think out of some
kind of uh
minimalist momentum minimal smoke so
we're the opposite in that way then oh
so you like stuff
i'm not a hoarder but because i can
throw things away but i have a shopping
addiction i think
like when i'm on the road like i was in
oklahoma for two weeks
i just i bought a bunch of stuff you
know what i mean and then
oh my god i went to todd snyder and i
bought um i got these shoes
you know
because you know but you're wearing them
so they're they're actually you're using
them and they're giving value to your
life that's awesome yeah but this is the
last time i'm gonna wear these this is
one time
this is like a wedding but yeah yeah
it's a red carpet dress who's a designer
do you know i don't know anything what
are you wearing bobby i don't know what
i'm wearing but i because i'm on a
native show called reservation dogs
right i just want to get into the spirit
of things that's your
yeah this is because if i was ever like
native and i was in a tribe back in the
day you know what i mean i would have
been a gatherer
yeah i'm not a hunter no i'm i'm gonna
weave baskets with the ladies yeah i
want to pick berries with the ladies you
wouldn't be the chieftain no no and i
would make after the hunt i would
probably make some let's some of the
guys make love to me
oh
yeah because i'm gay just because you
know yeah
yeah yeah
there's a power hierarchy you gotta know
your place in the hierarchy yeah you're
alpha male then
i don't even know what that means joe
rogan
joe rogan is the definition of alphabet
to me yeah if i if there was a picture
of alpha male in the dictionary
it would be joe rogan yeah yeah
yeah so you hoard stuff okay yeah yeah
but you can throw on wha when was the
last time let me call you on that when's
the last time you threw away something
that's actually valuable
valuable like something valuable to you
or valuable in general most things that
i buy aren't valuable to me there are
things that are valuable to me that are
like keeps sakes from my family and
stuff that i will keep forever so i like
in terms of like an old photo of my
father or whatnot so those kind of
things i keep but um
when it comes to like you know
aviator nation sweats like if some of
like somebody came into my house and
goes hey can i have six of those
sweatshirts or whatever i'd be like yeah
go take it okay my brother's come over
to my house and she's done a clearance
you know i mean like i'm gonna take this
this this i generally
really don't have a problem with so the
self-critical voice is serving no
purpose
in terms of because you're pretty you
know i've i'm a fan of yours so you're
known to be a little bit lazy sometimes
100 lazy yeah yeah so the self-critical
voice don't you think that it's
serving a purpose and fighting off the
laziness
beating off the laziness
the self-critical voice that i have
i've been able to come up compartment la
how do you say compartment yeah however
you say yeah
you're free yeah yeah
put it in a compartment yeah right and
um i'm able to like um
i'm a good avoider
i'm good at avoidance so for instance
right now um to avoid i i've been
playing stardew valley
you know what that is no
phone game or no it's a um you can play
it on your switch but it's on the xbox
and it's a farming simulation game and
so i like to farm you know i mean and so
and playing video games and doing stuff
like that
distracts me from
you know what really is going on okay
you've mentioned elsewhere in terms of
video games elder scrolls did you play
that yeah of course it's probably my
favorite game if i could live in a world
you played morrowind and skyrim i played
oblivion oblivion i played a little bit
of morrowind but i didn't like the
graphics back then but i really played
the can i swear on this podcast yeah i
played the [ __ ] out of um oblivion and
skyrim like
eight characters played it all the way
through i have to do all the quests that
type of thing what's your favorite thing
about those games
um why did you spend so much time in
that world because i i like games that
you can grind
what do you mean by grind so like
stardew valley for instance right
there's a lot of to the farm that's
farming right okay the same thing as
skyrim the reason why i like it is that
there's a lot of like
i have to collect a lot of these things
you know i mean i have to just
constantly pick things up you know i
mean yeah like for instance in skyrim
there's a mushroom called blister wart
mushroom that you can pick and then you
can make it into some sort of formula
right yeah yeah potion yeah right yep so
i would spend like
literally human 12 hour days just going
to every cave and picking up as much
blister wart as i could like that kind
of grinding
you know what i mean yeah yeah so you're
actually the randomly generated quests
that these gifts do yeah
for people like you yeah you don't get
bored that's the that's the fun yes
that's the fun for me okay yeah there's
always something to do and i find like
when when you play a game that's linear
like
there's certain games where you have to
go this way right i don't like games
like that yeah i like open world games
where i can make choices and i can grind
if i want yeah yeah would you stay in
that world if you could live in that
world in the in the elder scrolls world
that's how i feel
in reality or become like a uh animated
thing in there oh no say like virtual
reality we're moving towards that
direction oh yeah if you look at skyrim
you mentioned graphics it's become
it's starting to get realistic yeah like
i i i'll sometimes just walk around i
mean it's been a while but i'll just
walk around and skyrim yeah you can uh
there's code you can turn off enemies
and you just walk around really you can
just listen to music and just walk
around
that's what you did yeah yeah yeah yeah
i would do that wouldn't you do that
would you do it with me
you sure we would have a house together
oh i mean live i thought walk around no
no no no if you and i were able to go
into skyrim right and walk around
and live together would we make love no
no no man don't go there okay no no no
because we like girls man
that's right it's not gay you told me
it's not gay yeah yeah yeah all right so
you and i would yeah i would hunt you
would gather
but in that world there's no hunting
yeah but there is hunting i would have
the because we don't have to find
bandits we have to fight i'm not gonna
gather a bandit i'm gonna hunt them but
i think it's all about the potion you
don't need the bandits okay well we
could do this we could you could be the
guy that like defends our place yeah
right i'll gather all the um blister
award all the white caps all the
mushrooms i'll get all the food yeah i
mean i'll go to white run remember white
run yep right or winter hold and i'll
i'll do all the like quests that have
nothing to do with you know i mean so no
dragons though no no dragons but we
would have a banquet we'd invite the
dark dark brotherhood yeah right the
fighters guild we definitely invite them
mages guilds we'd invite them are you a
thief kind of guy i'm a thief guy yeah
i'm gonna be i'm for life yeah i'm a
thief guy for life and you still
wouldn't invite andrew schultz to that
no no no but what a piece of [ __ ] though
huh because let me just say something
okay i just want to get back to that
okay sure so i met him
at the montreal comedy festival and him
and i
are kindred
souls we really connected yeah
and he did my podcast he's done it
several times done his we've we've like
communicated on the phone this and that
and to me and then he invites whitney
cummings which whitney is a good friend
of mine but what i'm saying is is that i
know
andrew as well as whitney knows them i
don't think that whitney knows them more
than i do
right what if it was a competition like
it was a tie
you know and like
nba like a bobby lee versus whitney yeah
what what in what way do you think she's
better and what way do you think you're
better
i think it's all about gender optics
okay right so there's a comedian
he has all these alpha males coming and
he's like all right i can i have one
more seat left yeah whitney or bobby but
bobby's although i don't think there was
a lot of koreans there so he could have
used that card this is true right but i
think he went for you know whitney's a
woman that's better for optics okay so
she was a diversity hire for the wedding
yeah
i see it was it was pretty fun it was
pretty i have to say i don't
it was joe rogan yeah i know
his wife i get it yeah and then uh
whitney are those the living comedians
that were there
i spent the whole time talking to jose i
i think no i don't think there was that
many comedians so i'm kind of joking
about
it was a pretty pretty small wedding
yeah
you